but I did High School in Kansas City yo
can we do this without the cap yeah
thank you damn
you got nice hair no but see uh it's
just extra
yeah here's cool
all right so what's your name
my name your name my name is sale sale
where'd you grow up
I grew up all over I grew up in three
different places I grew up in
Granite City Illinois
oh
Kansas City Missouri
and basically Seattle Washington
you had Parents yeah
I got appearance I have a mother
yeah
where was that
I I never
met my dad until I was 21. wow yeah
how was life with Mom
uh
it was good I mean like what do you mean
mom was working yeah
um she loved you yeah
my mom put okay so okay so my mother
yeah she was a
she was strict but she put love
into me that's great
and I speak for me
she's a great parent yeah she was a
great parent but she was strict it's
hard for a mom by herself
I have particular beliefs
what are those
I don't like single mothers
they've got it hard
you said they got it hard it's hard as a
woman raising kids trying to make a
living put a roof over your head we all
make choices
so do the sort of their male Partners
right who bail on them right but it's
not always with the kids and how often
do you don't support them how often do
you hear a story where uh
the father is having issues with the
mother
there there is there is times where you
know is yeah the bail story
you know but come on man what what
father doesn't want to be a part of her
kid's life there's a lot I mean they
want it but they're not willing to do
the work that that's right put it like
this I'll just put it like this
um I got a lot to learn and I'm I'm
inexperienced inexperienced when it
comes to that how old are you I'm 33.
no kids I got a daughter 11 years old
yeah where is she
she
is with her grandmother
and you're and you're in La she's in
what city yeah uh
well I won't disclose the city but
you're not seeing her every night right
so her mother is Hispanic
the grandmother claims to be traditional
Hispanic
but doesn't know Spanish
and uh
doesn't like blacks
a lot of Hispanics have a hard time with
right so now I don't get to see my
daughter
no there's it it's never just one-sided
that the guy's a deadbeat and that's it
right right right right right and you
know uh but there are a lot of guys that
are just unwilling to get over that
hurdle
and do the work that's required to be a
parent see that's what I'm saying I
don't I ca I don't know their side I
don't know their story I just don't
understand that I just can't see that
I can't comprehend that
I cannot comprehend that
I don't understand that
you would want to be there with your
daughter
I see it as any parent man I'm telling
you I see you there's any parent would
man
I see it as any parent would want to you
know I'm saying like
have their children
why wouldn't you
because it's a lot of responsibility a
lot of time a lot of taking you away
from what you want to would you would
you rather be doing what does that mean
a lot of guys want to just hang out with
their friends and smoke and I don't know
chase girls and do whatever I don't
understand it no but there's a lot of
guys that Skid Row is full of them
there's like and that's why I say you
know
La is crazy
it's not just La though yeah the world
is crazy the world is crazy
I mean it doesn't I don't know if it
goes on so much with the black community
in in England or in
other parts of the world yeah
but in big cities in the United States
there's a lot of guys that just want to
bail I'm telling you I'm waiting to
spill something
I want you to ask punctual questions
what question do you want me to ask you
all right so I I mean you're not working
how come I'm not working all right so I
got a class A CDL
um
truck driver yeah I was on a truck my
trainer pulled the knife on me I had a
knife also but I never I never pulled it
my knife was in my backpack as my
trainer pulled a knife on you my trainer
pulled the knife on me why is that
we we we basically had a uh
uh we disagreed he was white yeah
and in my mind I'm like I know it's just
me and him so anything that go down I
don't care about that camera anything
that go down like me being black I'm
gonna be seen as you know what I'm
saying I I just know I'm gonna do some
time behind you and I'm not willing to
do that like you know what I'm saying
it's hard for black guys right I'm not
I'm not I'm just not willing to do time
if white guy and a black guy get in a
fight with no Witnesses like I was
guilty
that's how I see
90 of the time that's how it ends up
being whether that's the truth or not
that's how I see
you know so you know uh I'm like listen
man you you blocking the way to get off
the truck so if you step out the way
I'll leave I'm saying oh man go ahead so
he move out the way I get off the truck
um now now I'm explaining the Dynamics
Kansas City St Louis the Midwest
don't give a about
where it goes down at you know what I'm
saying like if you get into a fight or
whatever happens
even if it's in front of the police so
what
you know what I'm saying people don't
care about that you know so uh
what's the hardest part of being black
for young men
shopping
yeah shopping what do you mean because I
have a two terabyte flash drive of mad
videos where I walk in the store and I'm
followed everywhere
people be telling me bro oh you ain't
got no money just go to Target and steal
something real quick dude I get followed
up every hour I think you're stealing no
they don't think I'm stealing they look
for an opportunity for me to steal
I don't even get the option the
opportunity to steal if I was if I was a
thief I wouldn't be able to steal
because they so busy watching me
you're a thief the second you walk in
the store yeah
whether I got bags or not
but that's got to translate into other
things in life too
getting getting a job yeah yeah yeah
yeah a girlfriend or whatever I cannot
keep a job
that's why I'm on the street right now
in 2021 I lost seven jobs because I told
my supervisor you cannot talk to me like
that and you damn sure can't call me
that
I lost seven jobs yeah
I'm sick and I'm tired
and that's why I have
this strong beliefs that I have
what's the solution
two
to get to get a break as a young black
male
or female
women haven't heard too
solution to uh to get a break
I think it's dictatorship
what does that mean
well I mean that that's in reference to
to politics where politics are concerned
but
um I don't know honestly I don't
I don't think there is no such thing as
a break
you guys are just stuck with the lot
that we've
put you guys in
if white people put you into this
situation I'ma say this man I think that
uh
because I think the the racism
nowadays it's an illusion
but I but I me personally I feel like uh
as far as a break is concerned
you know this is how a breakup happened
you got people out there that believe
there is a such thing as good people
there's no such thing as good people I
don't believe in that
and then you got people that believe uh
there's a such thing as good white
people
good black people good Asians good this
good day you know what I'm saying uh
and then you got people you got white
people and different ethnicities I
believe oh well I'm not racist
and it's like this if you're not racist
when you see some injustice as a white
person
you need to speak up against other white
folks because if you don't you you part
of the problem
you there's no such thing as a good
white person there's no such thing as a
good black person there's no such thing
as a good person at all I don't believe
in that
I think uh for us to get a break is for
uh
education to I ain't gonna say be free
but education is definitely the issue in
the problem
a lot of people are uneducated
now I'm not going to say that
I'm not one of them
I got a lot to learn
you understand
huh how far did you go I went to college
you did yeah I'm I'm damn near away from
like a credit away from Associates
uh
uh I consider myself genius so but I
don't brag about it
I think you just did no I no I'm not
bragging about I'm not bragging about
you I'm not bragging
but I see it like this
but not what the reason I say education
is because I feel like our society we
use a lot of terms that we don't know
the definition of
one in particular
two in particular three in particular
well it's meaning God love hate brother
sister mom dad cousin all of that
is to me
now I'm explaining so basically what I
do is like I said with the with the
situation with the truck driving I
document time date and event I got like
300 pages
I've named it hate is a book with no
last page
uh I document my experiences and I write
my perspective about it
at the end of the book I have a debate
between love and hate love is a defense
attorney hate is a prosecutor and um
they're debating about Humanity
I have a full defense for hate but not
necessarily for love because I don't
think that I really know what love is
but I'll say this I feel like this it's
like
when it comes to love you have a man and
a woman right they create they create
let's say they they have a relationship
for eight years and they create a child
out of love
you know what I'm saying but at the end
of this eight years or somewhere in the
relationship they start arguing they
start fighting you know what I'm saying
and then they start to grow apart
but you love this person first off when
you have a child
that defeats choice you get no more
Choice after that you don't get to
choose to eat spaghetti on Wednesdays
anymore like you don't you don't get
Choice anymore
all your choices gone
you get a choice to leave your partner
no
you have a child
and you know what I'm saying um stick it
out no matter what no matter what and
when you tell when you give a person
your word
like we told you who's gonna be here at
12 45. I I told him I was like and I'm
not saying this is anybody's fault I'm
just saying like when you give a person
your word man
you know what I'm saying like I love you
like
a lot of people that's Finney
and I believe a lot of relationships are
fake because it's like you tell a person
you say I love you you know what I'm
saying and like
have an argument and turn around and be
like I hate you
you know I'm saying like you never loved
me if you can turn around and say that
in in argument you know I'm saying and
my thing is this you know I'm saying
like uh
when it comes to love like most people
or a lot of people
understand or believe that God is love
and love is God and they're
interchangeable
and God is eternal right so when you say
you love a person it don't matter
that person cheat on you a thousand
times oh yeah you got a lot of people
that'll be like no I don't care
no that's sucker well you shouldn't
have laid down with them then or you
shouldn't have said that that's your
fault
I don't give a with my daughter's
mom does like
she like
I have an obligation
I don't give a
now you know I'm not in love with her
you know what I'm saying but
the defense for that is basically like
you know what I'm saying at that point
in time I was young I didn't know what
love was I was thinking that I was in
love you I'm saying I thought that I
knew what was it what what love was and
it did this is another thing that's what
I'm saying I feel like you know what I'm
saying a person
you don't know who you truly are until
somebody come to you with some
information like hey session says she's
passed away
then you become a totally different
person
you mature from that right there because
people will make decisions
after they get a certain certain some
certain information that they would have
never made prior today
you know what I'm saying
I got a little cousin that you know what
I'm saying it was he was a jolly kid
four or five years old always smiling
always laughing
joking
when he got 18
his whole demeanor change and if I play
with him
like four and five years old
at 18.
he ain't gonna take that lightly because
what time has done to him and situations
has changed him his character you know
I'm saying and that's why a lot of
parents they think to themselves are you
still my baby because they still see
that baby you know what I'm saying they
still see that child but when when you
they don't what parents don't realize
and understand that your children have
went through so much during that time
you know what I'm saying that
they've become something totally
different
like you know what I'm saying but as far
but back to love like as far as love is
concerned it's like
yeah love is eternal
you don't get you don't yeah love is
eternal you don't get to leave
um
you gave your word
you know what I'm saying uh and and if
you do leave
you was just a liar
he was a liar a manipulator
I think that uh all human beings have
something fake about them you got people
that be like oh man that fake man
bro you fake
because you still haven't
figured out what's fake about you
and then stop doing that to involve
yourself with other people to not do
that
and now you're doing fake in other
people in front of other people people
are hip creatures man
I do not like people bruh I love people
but uh
so as far as as far as as far as the
word hatred is concerned I lived in
Montana for five years
yeah yeah yeah point three percent black
I wanted to know what hatred was
in my mind I wanted the closest thing to
hatred to me for me was uh
the Atlantic slave trade
and the position that black people are
in today
that was the closest thing to hatred
like like we was just talking about like
how like
um
the solution for black people being able
to have a break
we all it's like a universal
understanding that yeah black people
were like
they have it hard you know what I'm
saying
um
I wanted to know what hate was and for
me you know the position that we're in
you know I'm saying as black people I
feel like that's like the definition the
closest definition of hate
besides the Holocaust
but even though you guys have it hard
you have it tough yeah there's no
there's no debating that
I think the solution to that is not I
think a lot of people are looking for a
free handout you know you have to make
up for making it hard for me and just
give me a free handout
that's not going to solve anything
agreed I think the solution and you
probably know this is
to just just work anyway just do it
anyway even though you're getting racism
and short
a short stick and you're getting a lot
of
tough breaks yeah you just tough it out
and eventually after a generation or two
people are going to see black people
differently nah no I don't believe that
I don't believe that
you have to why because that's how
change will happen I I don't believe it
I think that change comes from you guys
because you guys have the voice uh you
know I'm saying nobody will listen to us
you guys have way more of a voice than
we do I know but but I I think it's
going to require it yeah hard work yeah
it's going to take change on both on
both the white side and the black side
but see that that change comes from
accountability
in every person it's going to require
work on both sides yeah accountability
and if you guys just
despite the short breaks the shorthands
the bad hands you're being dealt you you
you tough it out and try to make it work
people are going to see that and respect
that and be like you know what these
guys are really trying hard work ain't
respectable
successes
no hard work is respectable nobody cares
unless you have money that's not true
yeah it is
look at all the homeless people on Skid
Row don't nobody give a about their
hard work they're not working hard
they're not working hard they working
hard to get off drugs or trying
all right all right let's let's put Skid
Row to the side yeah please
say uh let's say
man homeless people are the great matter
in the back of most of society's mind
man
tell me I'm lying I don't know I mean if
you're gonna like put homeless people in
the equation I think you're going to end
up distorting it
why you say that because they're they're
they've they're not they're not even
trying they're not going to try they're
not going to try I've seen it when you
say there you're making a blanket
statement and and and that's what I'm
saying like I can make a blanket
statement about cops I can make a
blanket statement about Asians I can
make blanket statement about blacks
I make blanket statements they're
addicted to a drug it's keeping them
from doing anything homeless people are
yeah not all
99.9 percent are uh how about these I
also make blanket statements yes I do I
make blanket statements about blacks you
know what I don't like dealing with
blacks I'm gonna be honest with you when
I see black people especially in La I
walk straight past them I don't ask them
for nothing or nothing even back home I
don't with no blacks
except for the ones that I know and
Kansas City Kansas City is is is Kansas
City got a street that was named after a
slave owner called truce where you got
black on the east side white on the west
side
now if you want to talk about
uh
uh homicide and you know what I'm saying
the the the the the the
the the the murder rate Chicago and
cities like that St Louis and stuff man
black people kill black people you think
I'm gonna walk around one of their
neighborhoods
no I don't with blacks because if
me and you walk down the street and
can't see they're gonna try to kill me
not you they're not gonna give a
about who's this dude man whatever
they're gonna try to kill me
a black person yes and that's why I
don't with no white person's gonna
shoot a black person before they shoot
me huh
huh that's like you're saying future if
you walk through the tough neighbor the
black neighborhood in Kansas City you're
gonna get shot by a black person
I didn't say I'm gonna get shot by a
black person but I'm gonna be Target I'm
gonna be targeted before you buy a
doctor yes really yeah
yeah Kansas City and Chicago are tough a
lot of cities are tough yeah San
Francisco Oakland and so I equate that
to uh uh Hitler in the Holocaust
he killed other white people
they didn't kill blacks or Mexicans or
no he killed other white people
and so that's why I draw swastikas on my
clothes you do yeah right here
oh
you have swastikas on your fans
yeah
cause black folks don't like other black
folk as a matter of fact you know what's
crazy a lot of people I feel like this
that's what I said one thing I have seen
and I'll say this on camera
that I see how black the black community
does not like to see one of their own
get ahead crabbing a barrel
they don't want to see anybody climb out
crabbing a barrel
success
people respect
even even that they don't respect
especially if you want your own kind
I've seen it
it's okay so some
some people fear success
is that too
but when when a black person is is
making
their way through life and getting ahead
yeah
they they seem to hate it yeah
because
see that that's why I said about hatred
what I realized when I lived in Montana
about hatred
when they see me they'll come up to me
and hey how you doing you got family out
here what brought you out here
they weren't necessarily interested in
what I was doing out there
it was more so like I moved
up here to get away from you to not see
you you know what I'm saying and it's
like
what are you doing up here
and it's not the fact see this is a
thing
in my eyes
like damn you hate me because I'm black
no they don't hate you because you're
black
you know what I'm saying like that's not
a reason to hate somebody
you know what I'm saying like for you to
hate me I had to do something to your
wife your son your cousin your brother I
would have to do something to do
something to you you know what I'm
saying that that would warrant hatred
but but
see what it is is the fact that I see
you up here and I was trying to get away
from you and now you hear
and now you reminding me
of what I did to you back then
which is the guilt that I gotta deal
with now
I had a situation where I was living in
Montana the first year I was out there
it was a white dude that lived across
the street every day hey how you doing
hey can I help you with your groceries
help me with my car everything but he
didn't know my mother just passed and I
wasn't trying to deal with nobody
and so it was like
you understand for a year he was just
cool with me one day he was like Hey you
better slow down I wasn't doing no more
than 25. he's like hey you better slow
down second day everybody slow down it's
third day everybody slow down or else
you know what I'm saying the third day
he said it it was like
I was hopping out I was getting out the
car and I was slamming the car door so
it was like
my ear hurted but my brain didn't catchy
I went in the house I went upstairs sat
on the bed some said look outside
I look outside the window this
sitting on this truck bed
polishing his rifle
now he didn't know that I was looking to
kill somebody at that time too
I was
but I was already a Target in Montana I
had become a Target in Montana
they was with me keying my car
with my girl all kind of
you know what I'm saying so
I get in the car
I I ain't even gonna go into that that
part of the story unless you asked me
punctual questions but basically like
this is the guy who was helping you with
your groceries at one point or offering
to right
so he made an effort
yeah but you can you can like but you
don't turn that into a no no no this
this is the thing this is the thing this
is the thing when I go eat at these soup
kitchens right
you'll be asking for seconds or whatever
and they'd be denying food
like we don't stay on the streets or
something like we stay on the streets
How You Gonna deny me food this is
another thing
who paying the lights in this
if you getting donations
you mean to tell me y'all paying the
lights every month but you can't give me
an extra plate
that
you know what I'm saying like like and
then
you give me a paper plate plastic spoon
and fork you know what I'm saying
canned good food
you know what I'm saying but you
volunteering
twice a day five times a week
you coming in on a full stomach at lunch
time you going to Chipotle in a beamer
come on man that
where the rest of the money at
where there is some money at
no that so I I see it like this if
I'm in the desert starving and I'm
already laying in the sand and and
you coming up and you got food and water
and you say Hey you hungry and I say
yeah and you splash water on my face and
throw the food in the sand I'm going to
eat the food because I'm starving you
know what I'm saying but when I get up
and I get energy I'm not gonna respect
you
I'm not going to respect you like you
didn't do for me and if you try to
go in front of people and be like yeah I
helped that guy out no you didn't
you never helped me as a matter of fact
I ate that food on my own
people can do things but that don't mean
they're always genuine about it
I don't know I think that's
we got a problem
you said we got a problem why you say
that
blacks and whites
that's not a problem to me
it's a problem but she it's been like
that so long and nobody gives a
anyway
to be real with you the people that say
that they give a don't
because there's no action behind that
it's a solution every problem
what's the problem though
it's not a problem there's a problem for
each person
but I could I could talk about my
problems all day
I think I think what the problem is is
education
our society is highly uneducated we use
words every day that we don't know the
definition of and it doesn't make any
sense
people are they have kids out
of wedlock we we we we we we
that's why I say we I'm not excluded
from this
nobody is
I think that's what the problem is the
problem is accountability
nobody want to take accountability for
the that they do wrong
we just all point the finger
racism is the problem racism is a
problem that's the problem man that
look in the mirror
that's what the problem is
everybody got their own issues
that's why I say I could sit up here and
talk about my own all day
but
forgiveness love understanding yeah
forgiveness what is forgiveness
because if you don't allow me if you
don't allow me
my cousin arrived the gas station look
look
all this snitching now shut the
up
so this will happen right
I'm in school
for nine months
and that's another word that
don't know the definition
of snitching
are you a snitch
and that and this never
seen a dictionary
the same talking about you
a snitch same that got a
uh middle school education
that pisses me the off when I
come across people I automatically
assume people most people are
intellectually inferior to me
unless they show me otherwise
but anyway it's like you know what I'm
saying like
I was in school for a whole year
cousin called me
hey uh
I don't know if you got nowhere to go
for summer vacation but if you want to
you could come here
you know what I'm saying so I go I go
out there he rob a gas station behind my
back without telling me or nothing
you know what I'm saying
he tell his he tell his mama that I
helped him do it
then he lie and say I'm snitching on him
you know what I'm saying and it's like
at this time I had no record
you know what I'm saying so I got credit
for Tom served but I find out the whole
year that I was in school
he robbed eight gas stations
now he do his time he get out he trying
to get in contact with me
oh man I need you to forgive me
all right yeah I forgive you
under the thought that we about to talk
about this
hey man so why don't you go back and
tell everybody what really happened no
man that's the past
that's the pass
what
you mean and tell me you up
my whole life I can't get a
passport
can't own property can't get a gun now
and that's the pass
you know what I'm saying and it's like
but then you won't even let me vent
about this you don't want to hear
nothing I have to say about it
so how in the if I can't vent about
this and get it off of my chest
even to you at least
man I don't know I'm gonna forgive
you and I ain't let this go
that's why I say what what is
forgiveness you got to be able to let
some go
to forgive that's how I see
and if I can't vent about this I
can't let it go
which means I cannot forgive you
I don't forgive you
no and that's another word up
yeah but I ain't even gonna go there
because you got all black people hey man
that means so what I don't care
I got my beliefs on it just like
everybody got their beliefs on God love
hate you know what I'm saying oh yeah
that's my brother that's my cousin
that's my news that's my dad
I don't believe in none of that
I don't believe in that
I don't give a
I don't
people say all the time bro
man
I think that
what we do is we regurgitate a lot of
that we hear
you know what I'm saying instead of like
I actually read Minecraft
Hitler's book yeah I read that and
a lot of people don't know Hitler was
homeless man
and and what he wrote about that that
made me cry
you know what I'm saying and it's the
thing like
at the end of the day
man I just feel like man we all live in
a human experience and we all experience
you feel me life you know what I'm
saying so uh
you know Hitler was a man
that's how I see anybody is capable of
that type of hatred
that's what I believe anybody's capable
of that type of hatred
everybody is capable of that type of
hatred this is then this is another
thing I want to say this real quick
you you could be walking down the street
and somebody just hate you
they want to do a harm to you or hurt to
you like damn you hate me like that you
know what I'm saying but in the same
breath it's like
you know what I'm saying
you can't just go out on the street and
just pick that person and be like I want
to love them
and do everything in your power to just
love that person
you don't even know them yeah but you
don't know me to hate me either
so you telling me you can just pick me
and just hate me based off what I look
like or cause I'm in your vicinity uh
line of sight or whatever but you can't
pick me and love me
like I could just go and pick anybody I
want to on the street I don't give a
like anybody and just love them to
death
and can't nobody stop me
that's that's
how I see it world would be a beautiful
place
man
I'm believing that either
people choose to hate
instead of love
thanks
actually interesting talk that was great
man I apologize if I just you know I'm
saying ramble
no it created a couple conversations
you hate hateful conversations hopefully
hopefully not
maybe there's a solution here somewhere
yeah conversation